it's Restaurant Week here in Las Vegas
and more than 200 local businesses are
taking part need to make a reservation
oh it's hard to get one now eight news
now reporter Victoria Saha takes a look
at why restaurants always look forward
to this time of year
[Applause]
things are heating up as Chef Bradley
Ogden's kitchen we have some orders in
already so we're also pairing
for our guests Sam Marche Bacchus who
are coming in for restaurant week every
other ticket seems to be Restaurant Week
tickets
colonies this French restaurant in
Desert Shores is just one of more than
200 restaurants coming together to offer
a special menu when we crafted this menu
to do something for everyone so on the
lunch menu we have our famous burger we
have a vegetarian dish owner Rhonda
Wyatt says taking part in restaurant
week goes beyond just eating out as a
portion of your check goes through Three
Square Food Bank you know that that
hunger in southern Nevada is an issue we
love being a part of a community a
restaurant community that is rallying
around three Square three square one of
Nevada's largest food banks things have
gotten better but we still have a lot of
need out there in the community three
squares new with CEO Beth Martino says
they've seen a 25 increase in families
going hungry last year they generated
200 thousand dollars from restaurant
week which helped them buy six hundred
thousand meals for those in need whether
you're looking to dine on the Strip or
check out a local spot with a great View
Restaurant Week is the perfect
opportunity to try something new and the
best part is that with every butt you
take you know that your money is going
towards a great cause Victoria Osama
eight news now